cda want de branches louie by exota en
stress
turn your beauty picassa vinkt if you're
doing completes the right now or has
just you the you can reliever l'étude
increase in stress levels
ah spin happening
the last year and en kan je mouth ethics
is free tips die heft discards during my
phd journey
she de firth isabel
time management the second one manager
social in fire mens en de burden van
een lion ewout a mindset gift
hey euhm shelter as a phd student at now
and then donders institute of neuroscience
zo shop of the first things you and
stylish is if you're actually stressing about
the detrimental level
and of the taxi pusher my podcast
peace on earth science podcast cup die
usually van also pilling paolo
barbieri talks about stress and anxiety
becomes thatcher people lie  can not
sleep anymore for longer periods of
time and her think this is really good
roelof van to just have in je in the neighborhood
of your mind
anyway just go over few days and jack
aa en m  ace silent sleeping well and me right
and problems a lion b or
stressful exam exam and i think that
's fine but if you're not sleep him
for longer period of time
and that freaks out pom words tempers and
or the man are you  polly had to be of
value weight some of de habets
en mindsets de en uw haar zo outside of
just taking care of yourself so exercising
sleep a
something in wel aldo shine vinckx a cause
i've discovered that one finger really
important if you ask you  know yourself
juni wel interns af what arjo efficient
working hours
so remember why was in high school
and if she in my bachelors de august
spent hours in the evening and also in
with to studying something with my fans and
relic estimate be for every exam
fashion and  daring the exam proteins
crash picasso with extra oil x-axis sit
and so deduct exam address for god and
briefing what some of my fans can do
this or inhibition study six and three teams
to feel i worked
paris inc one of the lesson  s and learn
from this is a unique to be mindful
about I am by optimal parents there so
quite simple family and grandma optimal
parents there in the morning
and the sep the early zo from around six
to and we say you know where one can
perform you  well and I have focus
you on this cool bag bad guys your
to fors myself to work outside or
spectators to the fridge
so for medux mosque programming and
doing the moor can technopark or my phd
he already does for poker or time in the
morning
and  and in the off I was still want
to work all my beauty and do you want such a
breeding farm watching' and lecture by
find the import and went for you is
nature necessarily follow my schedule
and break up early
what the muslim be caught  is to know
when you're peak power arm zo this could
be in the none
the mouth of mundo
and there is fin  e is just impotent u
make use of the window and when we wet
beecher herself is pure now working out
side of the aan windows so effink haven
in this release edwin about yourself for
mee at least your quarrels mistress
levels and allah's myth just here my
dwelling and your tell me have everything in
the back of my mind all tomorrow theres
another morning and problem can work
really well it time would secondly ph
is about social connection en de en [ __ ]
a lord of all star student therapy yes
you can relate you  the often in it
loses esmee effe tendency to push of
fans and family
ow and i think this is finally kind of arms
after which he never has anything picasso
gates that is for you
if you this
for zeppelin juffermans cashier least
rest en you lift and finish all this way
we work and giving lectures en bla bla
bla en en in your second you have the
right person you also lose rest en
defroidmont so be one so you can't
peterink and willie's in and before
you k  now what you're in east social
isolation
by your own terms and not seeing and
new another imac set for your
colleagues and think this is really
think habets alpajim
your fans and family away when you're
feeling stressed over the  longer term
can really be detrimental to yourself
en if you dress siety levels and that
happen nexi our talks about there in the
house podcast this your body actually
cyclic
sir de hormone sta increase your sense
of loneliness and fair en paranoia en
viewer in social isolation very  long
time so i think it's really important
you if you feeling fast and you know you
of the tendency when stress of people
way to just make regular white my free
yourself to certain people and if this
is once a week or perhaps in the morning
for quick  coffee that builds tension
jeweler old yourself to that schedule
to help a sensifit stains in you
something in your team er santing rita that
casper haps in the moment it won't feel
that  night to see ya person that box
realy chest and when i must i be caused
a ban on a longer term in this weather
for your sense of social connection and
if you really really interfer dit which
a long french arno de is a een haas
point show  and days or so together
patch of animal and just frank
box helps you
or if you can have bad such as can
tell you summut when your
channel avatar finder friendly the pipe and
steeldeck patch for lobith if you're
feeling their brutality and  he went there
can really help and the last went and
because the sap building is in my opinion
polly the muslim what if we become the
most difficult to work on where your soul is
lo and with which so no or mindset
time is a phd we will i  strongly link to
your cell phone and iphone this is really
per bottle in job where people powder
ladder
value in their job om zo freaks and
poetry hoe het narcis doctors
scientist' on the sky of professions
there have strong sense of word of their
work which in journal is relic the wage
or the breakdown is for you will ealing car
fantasy 2 u the value of hang work and
info for fast doing there although there for
you well producing that much or reviewing
handsome formation and both than a sense of
self  word would already would start planet and
this can be really really done for r
us and i site die levels if you're in
a longer period af just expert gains
and keep on apprentice and stuffing and
stuffing if so from the vinckx hyde your and
he  went moses of the people and theater
release table and to this is to find
something els toe as also appel yourself
or two words zo live in this has to be
something that you identify jas uit site
af what you're doing and at work zo voor
yourself or for mireille identify ss
science is from an outsider for i if
she can you identify and be yogi cause
i'm really
active in the yoga community aan mit en
een now also identify and be youtuber
outside for you and copy something like
maybe you  're a m  other father and you
identify and speak and get parent or
perhaps your a cup and juliet a
live
you have a nose for it out of baking
and the [ __ ] received is that it's not
necessarily that she just after a
hobby wat you hefty or another
self identity
dat you can place your attention on
allen zo try to think about something
that we need to find you
en de really cash your happiness in the
sense is if yes a hope
you always had nff suntip shirley
and become more powerful  then they hope ten dam
lo and see you next time hi